hello everyone.welcome just starting a
15 minute timer so I can more easily
keep track of time we are gonna be
talking about Elon Musk we're gonna be
discussing all the cool things that Elon
has been doing in the world and we're
gonna be maybe adding a couple of points
of challenge to the conversation as well
because it's really important to be
willing to have the tough conversations
around certain philosophies around
certain ethics around certain ways that
we're gonna be progressing forward as a
civilization because there's not really
enough of it that's currently happening
alright so let's start off with kind of
a lot of what's in the news today a lot
of what's in the news is the boring
company so this is something that is
really important because people hate
traffic
people hate stress from traffic and
people want to go from point A to point
B faster there's a couple things that
come to mind when I think about this
first is that I'm not sure if digging
holes underground is better than
vertical takeoff and landing aka VTOL
I'm not quite sold on it yet and one of
the reasons why is because the tunnels
can't move at all the tunnels are dug
once the vacuum tubes thrown through it
and then you can't actually move that
tunnel in a different direction and that
it's just static forever that tunnel
versus VTOL you take off you go wherever
you want it's a more difficult obviously
requires a lot of energy it requires a
huge amount of Federal Aviation
guidelines we got to figure out how like
what exact Heights that different V
tolls are going to be flying at so now
that's a good question is that is it
actually worth it to spend millions and
billions of dollars building out this
infrastructure same thing goes for
Hyperloop by the way Hyperloop from here
too from SF to El
okay what about VTOL what about just
making flying easier it's an hour and a
half to fly so I'm not quite sure if we
need all this infrastructure that we're
building maybe we're not thinking far
enough advanced maybe we haven't
calculated all of the different I want
to say Ellen's extremely intelligent and
this team is extremely intelligent to
the point where they've calculated all
of the different ways that they can
engineer and design these different
solutions to transportation but at the
same time it almost seems as though why
are we picking something like tunnels
underground rather than investing a lot
of interest in vertical takeoff and
landing or in making it easier to just
fly from place to place so I think we
got a little bit of skepticism there I
think it's healthy skepticism in terms
of transportation and overall I think
the general idea of fixing transits is
crucial but one more aspect of that that
I think is really important is location
agnosticism is now becoming more and
more popular meaning especially with
technologies like virtual reality and
these haptic feedback suits you can get
immersed into an environment that looks
just like somewhere that's 10 hours 20
hours away even by flight and just like
that versus needing to actually fly
there so or go by Hyperloop or boring or
wherever they're so with location
agnosticism I actually don't know how
important it's going to be to need to
transit from point A to point B as much
and people will desire to move next to
their homes more in the future work next
to their homes or in their homes work
either next to or in their homes rather
than an hour or two hour drive away from
work that's really really bad for a
daily commute so that's the first thing
now a piggyback on transit is the
electric cars
Tesla's are great Tesla's are really
important to electrify the way that we
transitions then just pushed out 15,000
electric buses onto their streets
there's like 50 electric car companies
in China
so this is really important that we
start getting this right I'm pushing
towards electrification but how exactly
are we doing that because the
supercharger grid is a great idea and
being able to go and drive across the
country in supercharged really quickly
or even just go into your house at night
plug in so let's talk a bit about the
tiles and then we'll talk about where
the actual energy comes from because if
the energy is coming from the tiles on
the roof solar tiles and then that's
powering a generator at home and that
generator storing the energy for you to
use at a later time in your car then
that actually makes sense because you're
using solar and you're not burning
fossil fuels versus if you're just
burning coal and gas in order to power
the Tesla that's electric it almost
doesn't even make that much sense why
don't you just burn gasoline for oil why
wouldn't you just do that instead and
what exactly are the costs of those
things so we don't actually not actually
very familiar with those costs and we
need to figure them out better we're at
least published studies about them and
figure that out so if you're skidding
energy from your roof and you're driving
your car that sounds like a very ideal
situation and storing it in that
generator for use in your house as well
during the evening when there is no
solar energy Wow sounds really great
really that's a that's a that's
something to applaud is that whole
ecosystem at home solar energy power at
night power the car that's all really
great ecosystem I remember posting about
that like two years ago about how that's
a really great ecosystem there for every
home now okay so that's about solar and
about energy now what about
electrification of cars and trucks and
what do we do with the batteries that
are left over okay so we make a bunch of
electric trucks they're the ones driving
goods around do we really need do we
really need trucks in the future that
are moving goods around on the streets
or can we throw them in VTOL in vertical
takeoff and landing
groans and ship them across the
different locations well of course it
can't carry as much but maybe it's just
more efficient who knows we need to
actually study these things and figure
them out in more detail so what are we
gonna do with these batteries right now
I haven't had really good answers
besides recycle okay so you use a
battery for 10 years lithium-ion battery
inside of a Tesla or truck or car and or
generator inside your house and then
what what what occurs with the battery
afterward what do we do with it does OK
gets recycled okay what do we do with
the recycled parts where do they go so
as we make things we got to know what
happens after 10 years because we don't
want them they'll end up in landfills
and we also just want to figure out this
whole process in general a little bit
better to be like this is what the
ecosystem looks like for the battery
after 10 years is what parts go where
this is how if any of the parts actually
have any environmental issues we need to
know all this information we need be
talking about it more and figuring it
out and I thought it was really
interesting that the that there was a
issue that was at the Tesla plant where
he had they had over automated some of
the things that were going on at Tesla I
thought that was interesting because
most people talk about over automation
as not something that's typically an
issue and so I think it's really
important for people to understand that
humans need to still be a part of the
equation and a really good way to
understand that is to look at the Tesla
what happened there and be like huh okay
over automation is actually a problem at
time so we need humans in the equation
otherwise we may have some issues
imagine in healthcare where there is
over automation or in autonomous
vehicles over automation so we need to
be careful as we transition to make sure
we don't put human lives at risk as we
transition so haha so so if we can
figure out how to really make
that we're transitioning to robotics
artificial intelligence and automation
in a way that is safe and in a way that
is secure in a way that is for everyone
then that's great but if we're starting
to hurt people along the way or hurt
like we experienced with the the Tesla
line I don't know because of the exact
nuances of it but that's a great good
example of humans need to be in the loop
because you can over automate things and
then things can go wrong maybe one day
in the future that won't be a problem
that we can just over automate
everything and then it won't even be a
problem it's better than having humans
in the loop but for now humans need to
be in the loop and a lot of things so
last point about the skepticism with
electrification and then we'll move on
okay so skepticism with VTOL versus
boring then skepticism with
electrification based on where are we
getting the energy from and also what
are we doing with the battery and last
is I still don't understand why we're
not investing more of our time and money
and resources into nuclear energy
because fusing atoms in things like the
Ptolemaic reactor and being able to
bridge the strong nuclear force and get
through it and then use less energy to
fuse atoms than we can then we get out
of it that is actually a sustainable
forever source of energy for the future
we just need to figure out how to do it
so I still think that if we can figure
out how to fuse atoms that VTOL and that
any other way of transit will actually
be SuperDuper powerful so I'm just
interested about exactly why we're not
doing that as well well we are but we're
not investing enough of our energy into
it we're still investing our time into
more so other forms of energy so all
right
another aspect about boring that I just
quickly want to touch on is what
happened what it lets up with this
flamethrower because the playfulness of
a flamethrower is kind of funny right
because you're like cool let's buy
flamethrower and let's you know go
outside and just click the button and
watch a big ball of fire fly out the
front and let's hold it for a bit and
watch them cool and just like have that
be fun let's go burn paper or burn
whatever you want to burn on the street
a little patch of grass whatever you
want to do but it can get dangerous
really quickly not only with people
using it to hurt or kill other people
but also to burn buildings down and
stuff a a flame thrower is this it's
kind of getting close it's like probably
above a knife in terms of how danger it
is and below a gun so it's like if Ilan
started saying I'm gonna make knives or
I'm gonna make katanas or swords or
whatever you people would be a little
skeptical I'm sure people are a little
skeptical we'll have to flamethrower I
get it supposed to be like funny and
stuff but instead of a flamethrower why
not make something that's a little bit
more I guess educational or important
but ok so that's that's that I
understand the importance of having fun
for sure but I don't know exactly if
this is the right way to do it
so moving on so we talked about boring
we talked about Tesla now let's talk
about neural link and open AI so these
are of course crucial things for us to
figure out so we have both brain
computer interfaces with neural link and
then we have open AI to figure out how
to make AI friendly and and work
together with the human race so with
with neural link I'm not quite sure how
many people are going to just openly
just take a neural prosthetic and jam it
into their brain and just trust that
they're not going to be manipulated in
some way now that being said I think
it's important for us to figure it out
because I think brain computer
interfaces are definitely going to
happen in the future
almost certainly are gonna happen pretty
much unless an asteroid hits us or we
fall to nuclear war but almost certainly
brain computer interfaces are gonna
happen so
so we should figure that out but how are
we going to bridge the ethics and the
philosophy of whoever's making the
neuro-link or whoever is making the
brain-computer interface so we basically
have to put all of our trust into
whoever is building it to believe that
they are a benevolent benign character
and that they care a lot about humans
and not as much about just rampantly
driving them their own selves profit and
wanting to control and dominate other
people megalomaniacs so we got to be a
little bit careful in that sense and
that's is that one's especially
important with people that are jamming
neural prosthetics into my brain that
that they're very non psychopathic that
that's that's very important so
eradicating things like disease though
like neurological disease crucial so
this is where brain computer interfaces
are fantastic figuring out how to
actually eradicate disease brain disease
from people's lives is really important
and humans have a bunch of different
examples of of motor diseases or of
visual diseases like macular diseases or
tons of other sort of of ways that are
impeding our way of having really strong
mental health and so fixing that with
BCI's is a crucial part of our future
our 15-minute timer ran out I'm gonna
flip it one more time so I'll be done by
the time this timer goes back so we'll
be closing the video before 30 minutes
it's done now with open AI I think that
this is again very very important
initiative right I think Elon is partly
doing open AI and neural ink so that way
people can see that hey I think it's
important to get people together to
understand that this is where we're
going in the future and that if we have
the right SS and philosophers working
together with programmers I think we can
really figure out how to make a friendly
a
and you you know companies that are
focused on Friendly AI aren't as sexy as
companies that are building AI to
maximize money so just keep that in mind
maximizing money is not as sexy as
maximizing ethics or philosophy within
AI so how do we make ethics and
philosophy of a I ask sexy if not sexier
than making money just to make sure that
everything goes smooth moving forward so
I think open AI is very important in
that aspect and we're trying to get some
people from them on simulation so I
think this last one's pretty big so I'm
gonna have to spend a decent amount of
time on it it's SpaceX of course and
SpaceX is incredible I mean without a
doubt it has helped move humanity in the
one of the most important directions
possible which is space colonization and
most people know the story of how Ilan
failed so many times leading up to three
times leading up to this fourth launch
and he was out of money and it worked
and now he's reusing rockets which is
amazing he's having them land after they
go and drop off their payload so and
what what are we putting in those
payloads were putting these commercial
resupply missions back to the
International Space Station we're
putting satellites into orbit around the
earth that are doing things like giving
us communication ability giving us
ability to to maneuver around I'm
absolutely like map like mapping earth
so not only do we have GPS Global
Positioning satellites but we have
communication satellites and we have
mapping of the earth and I don't know if
you've seen some of the satellite
imageries I would highly recommend
looking up daily overview it's our
friend Benjamin grant
he's on Instagram go look that up daily
overview it's fantastic and the
satellite images of Earth they're really
Oh scopic Leah we're awakening because
you get to see the Earth from this new
perspective and there's tons of other
information that is really important to
know that we get from these from these
top-down views weather patterns
predicting weather is really important
for us especially to evacuate people
that are closer to hurricane zones or
monsoon zones etc and then we have
obviously communications the way we talk
to each other
haha so that's obviously tremendously
important to continue doing so
resupplying the ISS with new projects
with new equipment with food with
projects with all the school stuff with
additional parts to the ISS that they
can add on so that's fuel for the ice s
so this all crucial these commercial
resupply missions and it's crucial for
moving us further into the space
perspective into the cosmic perspective
now now I think I'm gonna touch on a
point that's a little bit this again
it's not talked about enough it's that
we're going to Mars and Mars is great
and so is the moon these are great
places to go and and put humans put put
robots first have the robots build up
the environments for the humans to come
and live on so this is a good like path
obviously forward to colonizing the
cosmos at the same time I don't think
we're talking enough about what's gonna
happen as we're getting there and when
we get there because initially about the
last huh
almost two years now two years ago I
decided thanks to my friend Jackson that
I was going to write a book called Mars
race and I had written six drafts of
that book and I didn't end up publishing
it wasn't done anyway but the fact that
I was so convinced that it was so
important to write a book about
philosophy and ethics of this process
was enough for me to to really want to
bring it to the world now I'm working on
a different book that I think is more
important more to the heart which we'll
talk on a separate video right now it's
called knowledge time in the human race
and so okay take into account this so
you're going to Mars perfect shirt for
it by the way on your way to Mars you
have China that's right behind you
because there's only a certain window
about every 26 months I think it is that
you can launch a spacecraft to Mars
without while the orbits of Earth and
Mars are aligned that you can shoot off
and and and get there so because
obviously you're not gonna if the Stars
here you're not gonna Mars this here
earth this year you're not gonna launch
a spacecraft to Mars it doesn't work
that way so and that's also the same
thing for for communicating between
Earth and Mars if Earth and Mars are
here and the sun's and between it's more
difficult to talk so I believe it's a
couple minute delay I think it's about
like about a four minute delay or five
minute delay or something like that in
terms of timing of communication if
they're if they're next to each other so
if earth is here and Mars is here and
then the Sun is here then that's only a
four minute delay but then you think
about how compounded it would be if they
were much further away from each other
alright how much more multiplied it
would be okay so so as we talk about
this it's like what happens when China's
behind the u.s. what happens when
Russia's behind China what happens when
India's coming as well or European Union
or Japan or South America what happens
when other countries realize that we're
sending our best and our brightest
people that wanted that are willing to
go and that the best and the brightest
land from all these different countries
and then are they gonna be fighting over
land or resources some kid even asked
Elon like a day or two ago at a
conference about like yo Elon what's is
you're gonna be some interplanetary
warfare going on and you know Elon very
carefully it was like no like like
there's gonna there's probably some war
that might happen because we've had a
lot of war but there's plenty of
resources in space and on Mars but
at the same time like humans are at the
most primal sort of way wanting to
colonize as much [ __ ] as possible and
for themselves so right now I've been
doing a lot of thinking in my head and
if you really drop down to your heart so
if we take a breath and slow down and
think about it with our heart with our
feeling we feel into the earth and we
feel into ourselves and we feel into how
we should go together we should go to
Mars together right there's this whole
thing that he said that Oh like you hold
hands and cross the finish line at the
Olympics right that's that's actually
not a good analogy because we're not
saying hold hands and cross the finish
line together it's more like okay
whoever is able to financially and
intellectually afford to put all the
pieces together to go there great let's
figure out how to could bring a couple
other of people behind you that are also
intelligent and have enough to help make
it happen especially for other countries
on earth that don't have the resources
just resources right now to start space
programs so there's probably some good
philosophies that you can learn from
some maybe African countries South
American countries that don't have the
financial resources right now to build
rocket companies and send them to Mars
so so these so these sorts of ways to
figure out work together are absolutely
crucial so when talking about Mars just
really think about how we're gonna
collaborate and get there together think
about that how are we gonna collaborate
and get there together and work together
we do not want some Mars earth issues
smart people go to Mars smart people
look back at Earth and see a bunch of
conflict then why the [ __ ] would they
ever want to engage with us we look like
a bunch of stupid monkeys at that point
so how do we work together between Mars
and Earth especially as we send people
this is a conversation not for if for
now for today because it's gonna be in
ten years it actually be a serious
conversation by 2028 so to be talking
about an ounce early and Early's good in
this situation because we're trying to
your things out and prepare ourselves
for the future and if that was the case
then we wouldn't have as so many of the
issues that we have today if we would
just be a little bit more
forward-thinking and a little bit more
careful about repercussions and stop
being so short-term but look at things
long-term thank you long now foundation
for helping us think in the long term a
lot of our friends are there so I think
that maybe experiences we just had a
chasm on the show today as well speaking
about five Meo DMT and these psychedelic
and spiritual awakenings experiences
that really helped us and dip into the
oneness dip into our hearts and dip into
the feeling and when we do we realize oh
crap we have a lot of problems on earth
I was still in the effects we have a lot
of actualization to do for ourselves and
for our collective and then we're gonna
go and call a nice the cosmos together
at the same time figure out exactly how
to do that so I really want to be
careful to not have a class-based
speciation I think this is a crucial
topic that we talk about a lot on the
show and I hope it resonates with people
I'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below
but for bye economic status if we specie
eight will actually I think have
somewhat of an issue moving forward
because if you have very wealthy people
and very poor people there's not much
incentive for very poor people to do
anything and there's not much incentive
for very rich people to do anything
about the very poor people while very
poor people don't have access clean
water clean food clean shelter clean air
education or health care any of these
basic necessities that they need so food
for thought is make sure that as
technology exacerbates wealth inequality
there is some sort of a way to look back
at people at the lower SES and uplift
them faster than what's going on right
now even faster the gaps like this how
the gaps like the gaps like this how do
we bring the gap to like that so that
the wealthy still keep getting wealthier
but the bottom has moved up so that's
part of the book they're writing alright
we're coming to the end of the time
thanks for tuning in and listening about
what's going on with with what's
happening in the
in the Elon Musk world and in kind of my
thoughts around what's going on in the
Elon Musk world so again we talked about
VTOL and the potential that that could
be a better source for us moving forward
of transit than potentially boring in
Hyperloop and maybe just figuring out a
speed up airplane transit via airplanes
as well so just think about that think
about more design and engineering
getting the numbers out there for people
to to really study and figure out VTOL
versus underground transit or
above-ground vacuum transit then also
you can think about the Jetsons like
nuclear fusion powering these
hovercrafts that are assuming through
the air super quickly individual transit
like that sounds better
really that sounds a lot better how do
we get there faster and of course you
know making sure these hub caps don't
fall off and cut people's throats off
well you know the same things true about
AI in cars right now is that how do you
know you're sleeping in the back the
eyes not gonna just swear off their own
kill you right or kill someone else
so also talked about neural link and
open AI the importance of having them
conversations about Friendly AI moving
forward and AI safety and security
moving forward and also bring computer
interfaces and how to trust the people
that bring in other ethics and
programmers and philosophers into the
conversations that's so crucial moving
forward BC is and they're almost
inevitable that we're going to be using
them and lastly about SpaceX like
continue colonizing the cosmos super
important but figuring out how to work
together in that process and not cause
the class-based speciation in that
process is really really crucial how do
we get it from here for wealth and
equality to here I think it's a really
good way of understanding and looking at
it so alright we are done with our time
thanks for watching this this thoughts
on Elon Musk video greatly appreciate it
if you thought it was useful share it
with other people
that's crucial we're trying to
to grow our following trying to join us
subscribe with us give us a comment
below with your thoughts give us a like
as well and build something with this we
always said this content isn't just for
consumption it's for creation so take
this content and go write your own
thoughts about one of the things that we
talked about here or go to make a video
about some of the thoughts or go and
talk to someone else about the thoughts
maybe start a business I mean you start
a VTOL business figure out how you can
do that or it's again these are things
that are unsexy right it's unsexy for
for a eyes that are friendly and safe
and it's more sexy for a eyes that make
money so we need to really figure out
how to make safe and secure things more
sexy and less about the money being sexy
so go build go build go create and
that's it that's it join me on patreon
join us here help us grow this project
if you find this useful we'd greatly
appreciate your help and thanks for
tuning in and I'll catch you guys soon
all right I'm cutting too I'm cutting to
five now all right and I'm cutting
that's fine
last time it didn't do that with jordan
peterson though alright